okay I want to thank the organs of the
workshop for for having me here it's
pretty exciting to be to be part of and
I want to tell you my turtle is very
general and I will not go to tons of
detail although I'll focus a little bit
more on a result I was involved in but I
want to give you kind of a big picture
of of why quantum information theory is
our topic that's relevant to quantum
Hamiltonian complexity and because it
involves many concepts please stop me as
I go along and ask me to explain things
that you'd like to see more clearly um
so let me start by giving sort of the
big picture of why quantum information
theory might be an appropriate thing and
it goes back to really the original
motivation for Quantic meeting the first
place to define men who observed that it
was hard to simulate quantum systems
classically that if you did the naive
way you pay in an exponential cost and
from this he realized that they or he
raised the possibility that perhaps a
quantum computer might do a better job
than classical computer since quantum
systems clearly can simulate themselves
without exponential overhead then
perhaps you could even do this in a in a
more controlled way and from this the
whole idea of quantum computing and hot
quantum leaders having having
computational advantage came from this
first observation that a naive
simulation of quantum mechanics requires
exponential effort and this exponential
effort comes from the phenomenon of
entanglement so if you have n systems no
matter what your theory is if the
systems are in a product state meaning
you can describe the entire collective
system by an individual descriptions for
the N individual systems then of course
the number of degrees of freedom just
ABS you just add up the degree of
freedom of each for each one what
entanglement means is that you
essentially have an amplitude for all of
the exponential in n joint
configurations of the system which means
the degree of the number of degrees of
freedom scale is exponentially with the
number of subsystems which essentially
is what sort of a technical piece behind
five mins observation that that quantum
computing the quantum mechanics scales
badly when you try to simulate
and this describes the cost of
simulating dynamics or even of writing
down estates there simply to write down
a quantum state I'm a classical computer
generic that requires exponential effort
and so in this talk I want to address
the question of when a system is lightly
entangled can we do better so these are
kind of two extremes a product state has
no tainment at all and we can simulate
it efficiently we can write it down
efficiently we can simulate dynamics
efficiently everything's great a
completely general entangled system is
very expensive to simulate it's
exponentially more expensive but is
there something in between those two
extremes to what extent can we say that
something is perhaps lightly entangled
and requires less effort to simulate so
they give you a number of of stories of
where people have tried to use this this
kind of reasoning some successful some
less so and I'll identify some open
questions where we might push in the
future so one story where we've things
have worked we've understood pretty well
if you have a quantum circuit so this is
the the gate model you have a bunch of
qubits and you apply a bunch of unitary
gates to them so you have n qubits and a
series of T 2 cubic gates and we know
that you can do a classical simulation
in time that's linear and teeth and
exponential in a kind of entangling
parameter K and K can mean a few
different things so young she who
somewhere in the audience and igor
markov have proved that you can do it if
k is the tree width of the graph which
the graph induced by these interactions
which if you don't know what at me and
it roughly means sort of how far is this
graph from a tree how many vertices you
have to group together in order in order
to make this a tree graph another
version of this is due to your honor not
ivy Ron and Tony short and richard
joseph which is in which k is a maximum
number of gates crossing any one of
these of these lines and so these here k
is a parameter that interpolates from
zero if there is no interaction
between or one if there's if there are
no interactions between different cubits
and could scale up to be as large as n
in which case there would be there would
be no advantage and so this achieves the
goal i mentioned of having this
complexity interpolate between linear if
there is no entangling operations going
on and exponential if you have a
completely general circuit creating
large amounts of entanglement so in one
sense this is an example of using
quantifying entanglement and and turning
that into something which which is able
to control the complexity of a quantum
operation on the other hand it is a
little bit pessimistic it treats all
gates as potentially entangling and it
doesn't take into account the fact that
perhaps after you do some operations
even though the system could have been
very entangled in fact isn't very
entangled and so there's a sense you
know sometimes this pessimism is
justified if you're running Shor's
algorithm your problem you really are
going to generate a lot of entanglement
there is no shortcut assimilating that
on the classroom computer but there are
many many cases when in fact there isn't
that much entanglement and we can do
much better so but this is nevertheless
one example of the type of interpolation
that we would like to see on another
example which I will not spend too much
time on because it's been in a large
fraction of the previous talk are
one-dimensional systems and you know we
think these should be easy classically
or at least we thought they should easy
classically because I'm sorry quantum
leap because classically they're so easy
classically everything you can think of
for these systems is easy minimizing
energy is easy tapping the partition
function is easy sampling from the
thermal distribution is easy whatever
you like you can you can do a possible
if this is a classical Hamiltonian
quantumly of course it's cume complete
to ask me to ground state energy if you
have demand one over polynomial
precision but in a breakthrough result
or I guess series a result um it was
found that if you have a spectral gap
which is not too big I'm sorry not not
too small and a
and you don't demand precision that's
that's too small then you can solve this
in a in a reasonable amount of time in
some cases polynomial amount of time if
q'bert's aren't aligned and lions are
kind of like trees and Patrick and two
of the students found I guess an
unpublished work that this is this also
can be done for trees and here too we
have an example of of something where
the problem really could be hard it
really is chew em a complete so it could
contain a lot of complexity but by
looking at the structure of the problem
we found the parameter that parametrized
the complexity and in this case it
happens to be the gap the eigenvalue
gaps sort of tells you how long range
the interactions could be and then this
algorithm was able to identify that as
the key parameter that controls the
control is the run time so as the gap
goes down the runtime interpolate
between something very small and
something exponential that matches the
fact that this promised you may complete
when the gap gets small enough and just
to maybe this is also me you've seen
quite a bit before the the intuition
behind why these things work starting
with a spectral gap you can show that
correlations decay exponentially a
longer length with a additional effort
you can show that implies entertainment
area law and in turn an efficient matrix
products a description of course all of
that is before what they do in their
algorithm which is defined the efficient
description but simply just a habit is
already a precondition and the history
of this a little bit confusing because
Hastings first prove the area law kind
of directly by using the special gap and
brand out [ __ ] desk you show that these
sort of these two steps could be
decoupled so there's kind of a confusing
mix of conditions but in general if you
want one takeaway here is that the
arrows kind of go from left to right
here that you know the conditions on the
left are sort of the prior ones and
towards the right are generally implied
except I guess these two are our
equivalent I should have made that last
one bi-directional okay so that's
another example of how we found the hard
parameter that lets us interpolate
between
the parameter that controls the hardness
and if I could just take a step back and
say you know what is the strategy that
you want to do here if we want to model
a system as a spherical cow and then add
little Corrections like a in this case a
tail and it's sort of the the general
theme of a lot of physics you sell have
a trivial special case like a non
interacting theory and then you sort of
add correction to the theory as
perturbations and you're willing to pay
a cost that maybe grows rapidly with the
the number of these Corrections but as
long as you understand that's where your
difficulty comes from maybe it's not too
bad and there's a cartoon that also
explains this this pretty well you're
trying to predict the behavior of
complicated system then just model it as
simple object and add some secretary
terms to account for complications I
just thought of so that's that's sort of
the the big strategy except hopefully
the complications we just thought of our
are really the right ones and and we
haven't oversimplify of the problem so
that is that is the the big picture here
is to start with a very simple skeleton
and then hopefully identify the the
direction in which perturbations make it
make it harder and and and hopefully we
identify the right parameter and since
quantum information theory is in the
business of quantifying information and
quantifying how how much surprise there
is no system how much entanglement etc
hopefully quantum information theory
will have something to say about what
are the right parameters to to look at
so um and I will mostly focus on
entanglement in this talk I think that I
suspect that entanglement is the right
parameters that was sort of the the
intuition of a fireman originally and I
there's the one that people have
generally followed since then but I
don't want to show you just that the
situation is not complete you know it's
not all about entanglement and there's
this strange example if
very simple it goes back to the
beginning of quantum information of
stabilizer circuits which shows how
these general picture actually can work
in different ways so what is this
stabilizer circuit or what is it rather
a Clifford circuit so Clifford gate is a
gate is a gate you such that if you
conjugate a poly matrix by it you get
another poly matrix and so by Pauli
matrix what I mean is a tensor product
of the single qubit matrices I XY and Z
and what so this is a group of there's a
subgroup of unitary dates and is
generated by a certain collection of
single cubic gates which I won't get
into and control knocks and it's it's
very much not computationally Universal
it's a small subset of all quantum gates
uh and it's so you know to emphasize
this not Universal goddess min and canal
proved over 15 years ago that a Clifford
circuit can be simulated in with a small
overhead the time is linear the number
of updates and and each step can be
simulated in time that's basically n log
n if n is the number of qubits and one
way to get some intuition of what
mathematically is going on with the with
the Clippers is that the Pauli's can be
thought of the pollies can be described
by 2 n bit strings and they sort of look
like f2 to the two ends so it too and a
string of two n elements of f2 and the
Clippers sort of correspond to matrices
that act on these that belong to the
symplectic group / ft that's sort of so
these are kind of like f to linear
operations which kind of expresses why
they can't ever do things that are too
complicated and why it might be possible
to track them with a simple classical
simulation so if this is the exact
theory this is the simple one the non
interacting case how do you interpolate
so this is a very easy extension if you
have pain on Clifford gates and
everything else is Clifford then you can
do the same simulation at a cost that's
exponential in K and so you can smoothly
interpolate between
Clifford circuit and some and some
general one but the cost you pay now is
not with each entangling gate but with
each clipper game remember Clifford's
contain control knobs which are your
sort of classic entangling gate that
every experimentalist wants to do those
are free but what are not for you our
single qubit operations that might be
non Clippard so it's a strange beast
we're on the plus side we can simulate
some very entangled computations very
cheaply and that is actually useful
because this includes many examples of
quantum error correction which are
actually extremely interesting to get
practical simulations of to know how our
proposed architectures will scale on on
the other hand so we can do some
complicated things well but it's some
simple things like single qubit gates
then most of those it can't do very well
most of those are non Clifford and so
you pay exponentially for those so for a
lot of physical systems it's actually
not so good even though it is good for
submitting more complicated things yeah
so is there an interpretation of this
simulation this efficient simulation is
just a special form of some classical
simulation or is it really just that
this is a specific quantum element that
whose entanglement doesn't wreck you
like it usually
I I don't know it's pretty similar to
simulating non-interacting firmly honest
but those are still quantum does any
know it way to mount this to some simple
classical dynamics one reason why I'm i
think it's non obvious is that one
Clifford gate that interacts with that
say interacts only two cubits I believe
it still requires n log n time to
simulate and so the locality is
completely destroyed by the simulation
and so that's why it's not obvious to me
how to translator to some classical
process but maybe there may be there is
no one the audience is saying there is
either so okay so let's leave it as we
don't know when you say circuit k'naan
Clifford kids assimilable in that much
time is that time on a classical
computer yes sorry these are all
classical simulations but the quanta
commuters can do this and these are
quantum certain ways you can hear if
these are easy for client computers okay
good so um so this is a interpolation
parameter that is not you know this has
nothing two is really not entanglement
and so it's uh I'm trying to tell you a
unified message about entanglement but
honesty prevents me from saying that's
the only game in town however I'm going
to return to entanglement now then or
more or less than haven for those my
talk so another example in which
entanglement can be can be tamed and
where we have kind of a succession of of
where you know where it is basically the
relevant parameter is when we're trying
to find the ground state of a local
Hamiltonian so it's a problem you've
heard about a lot over the last couple
of days um and your Hamiltonian has high
degree so think of your Hamiltonian as
it's a two local hamiltonians that means
spatially local it means that each
interaction involves two huge it and so
you can think of the Hamiltonian is like
a graph the graph will be D regular
I should say capital d regular is the
degree of each vertex in the graph then
n systems each of lowercase D dimension
and this point here about the
Hamiltonian being an expectation this is
what's called PCP normalization and the
guarantees that the Hamiltonian has norm
that's at most one and I don't to go too
much in detail here just tried to set
the scale of the of the other side of
the Hamiltonian so what you can show in
this case or so this is pretty general a
pretty general to local Hamiltonian
where you can show is that even though
entanglement the ground case of
Hamiltonians in general can be entangled
in this case you can get an
approximation that's a product thing
there's zero entanglement and the
approximation quality goes like 1 over
the cube root of the degree so as the
degree gets large you get a better and
better approximate there there's a
product state that gets there's a better
and better products Kate approximation
to the ground state energy yeah you know
the question is is it known to be
optimal and you certainly don't have
good products eight approximations if
you have constant degree um I think okay
if you have it we are counter example
yes so that one-third of the exponent is
probably not optimal we have a counter
example where that should be replaced
either by one-half or by two I can't
immediately do it in my head which one
it is but our counter example look
something like that so random in here is
about of the order of n lambda min is on
the order of one hence the left that was
the purpose of the PCP style
normalization the Hamiltonian is an
average of local systems of each H sub
IJ is a term interacting cute it's I and
J and it has norman most one and the
overall hamiltonian is just an average
of all of those local trucks so
overall Hamiltonian has norm at most one
so all of its eigenvalues are you know
within a range of minus one to one and
so this yeah so that means that the
approximation error of one is trivial
and of one over a hundred is you know
the first non trivial thing you can do
but you would expect to learn them into
in like maybe one over N um well no I
mean it's think about suppose either
diagonal hamiltonians then this is like
there should be you know it's like it's
just like a general to CSP right you
expect yeah i'm sad value to be anywhere
between zero and one no I'm just trying
to map it to the to the you know like
that a lot of the Hamiltonians we've
been seeing the area rolling off right
then it's a sum of the Hamiltonian right
oh right right yes this eigenvalue gap
you are interested in is constant so
which is like 1 over X I um it's no
biggie i get very good cannot yeah no
obvious thing but like in fact alone so
when you're one D algorithm the eigen
value gap that enters is that for all
right that for that's where the Hamill's
really is a sum of local terms that's
right that's right so the normalization
is different from what they do in that
one D algorithm where the Hamilton is a
sum of terms yeah so what's the symbol
the fancy expectation it means an
average over IJ so that I tilde J means
edges in the graph means pairs I and J
are connected so the Hamiltonian is a
you know you have a bunch of cute it and
they interact according to some
there's interactions that correspond to
some graph and there's an interaction
here on each edge you have an
interaction and the overall Hamiltonian
is the average of all those interactions
so they I think the trick is that that
you are developing alike nation and self
and others like they just sum it up and
you are taking their expectation come to
body but it's also dividing by actually
you are not divided by n you are
dividing by mg n times d that's right
something that's important that there is
this D oh that's right thats makes the
three cry just because the DS in the
denominator in your in your form line
that's right if I was surprised how
could it be in the game right because
otherwise you could add dummy edges you
could add edges with a hamiltonian that
edge is 0 and the approximation we get
better and you know that should you
should be suspicious about seeing such
thing yeah um another question yeah yes
yes yes I'll come back for a second the
question is is this an example of
monogamy of entanglement I'll come back
to that in there I would say um yeah
we're now giving entanglement is sort of
I would call it a an intuition rather
than a theorem because there are many
manifestations of it but I'll actually
come back to a quite a bit and incoming
slaves good so um one consequence of
this is that because there's a product
state approximation for the energy that
means the ground state energy can be
approximated within NP you know you can
write down a product state efficiently
because it has a small classical
description of course there are other
things that have small classical
descriptions this is just one of them
but it's one of the more convenient ones
and so you'll hear tomorrow about the
quantum PCP theorem and this says if
you're going to prove a quantum PCP
theorem you had better not take the
degree to be too large so you can think
of this as you like it sort of backing
the quantum PCP theorem
Corner we already know that it has to be
on an expander now you know also that it
has to be an expander but also the
degree could not be too big so which is
of course quite different from the
classical case where classical PCPs are
perfectly happy to have very large
degree and the intuition you know I told
this result to two physicists who told
me that it's been long known and then
when you when you push on it they didn't
they say well actually I guess it those
the proofs from long ago prove it in
some very special case but it is sort of
an intuition from physics that there's
something called the mean field
approximation that applies as the degree
of your interaction gets higher so
people often do is start off the line
and then consider 2d and 3d and then you
can might as well take the limit to
infinite dimensions which you can either
have a complete graph or you can have it
be this thing called the beta lattice
which is like a ceili graph it's not a
tree that's a vehicle a decision tree
yeah I know it's not a sort of a knob
real it's a not really a lattice no but
it is it a tree yes it's an infinite
Kayla tree oh I see it's that kid you
that is the Kayla graph of the free
group yeah um and and people have often
so what people do in physics often is
they just pass the limit of infinite
dimensions interpret it as either
complete graph or this infinite tree and
you can prove that in these cases then
entanglement is usually not in that you
can often prove these case entertainment
is not an important part of the solution
that you can recollect entanglement for
the purpose of the solution and then you
can reason if it's true here then
probably it's true for for high degree
in general and in fact you see good
enough approximation there's often
already true in three dimensions so
already three dimensions there are many
cases when it's already described well
by this mean field intuition so it's
been a pretty productive way of thinking
about a lot of systems and it can also
be thought of in terms of the monogamy
of entanglement that if up
article is entangled with one the part
of it cannot be entangled with all the
other ones simultaneously and so if
there's going to be entanglement then it
cannot be a you know it cannot be
relevant to most of the edges it can
only be relevant to a to a small
fraction of the of the edges which can
be neglected to get the sort of error
that I'm talking about so the the
approximation that we prove actually is
a little bit more complicated a little
more sophisticated than the one I
mentioned before when I said before is a
special case the general theorem we
proved allows for the possibility of
grouping the vertices the cutest into
clusters and then getting an
approximation which is not product
across the individual systems but
product across the cluster so you allow
entanglement within each group but
required to be product across the
clusters and now this is the error term
that you get which is a quite a bit more
complicated but let me unpack it first
let me define this V of X sub I is the
expansion so X of a is a subset of
vertices and fee of x value is the
expansion of that subset and that means
is if you choose a random edge in the
graph that has one endpoint in that set
what is the positive that that other
endpoint will be outside of that set and
the average expansion you can also think
of it as the number the fraction of
edges that go between clusters um so
that's the first term and a question the
next term is the familiar one over
degree that we had before and this last
term is the is the average over I so the
average over clusters of the entropy of
the of the cluster so on I won't explain
a little bit this notation so when
Ashwin talked about entropy he wrote it
as a function of the density matrix of X
of Rho and here I'm writing as a
function of the subsystem and the way to
the way to relate those notations
if I might if you have a density matrix
row on systems ABC data dot then you can
define roasted a to be the partial trace
over all of the other systems so Rho sub
a I sorry rose superscript any means I'm
just considering system a of the overall
density matrix and when I write s of a
sub row I mean SF row superscript a so
this means entropy of those systems and
I'm just reminding you that the state is
row with the subscript and this notation
is better in cases when we have a single
state that we're always considering but
we're looking at many different
subsystems of it um yeah so what it says
this statement says yeah so i am
wondering about this because it says
something counterintuitive because like
your sensor you want to approximate the
ground state yeah and the way how you
are approximating if you your state has
no entanglement inside the clusters yeah
and has entangled man outside no the
other way around it has no one take them
into across clusters on the 110 go man
that across known even across clusters
it's the closed oh that means across
sorry yeah then it sort of the message
is clear okay good good s'alright yeah
yeah def just something that varies
um you're not actually getting so what
to what extent are you getting a picture
of what the ground state is you're not
right it's just some approximation the
ground energy but that's right but that
range of energies includes what
proportion of the space good so the
question is this produces an
approximation but to what end is
interpretation of the ground state and
it's not actually it approximates the
ground state energy but the fidelity
with the ground state could be very very
low it could be think of this I guess
this might be clear or tomorrow when you
hear about PCP but when you hear about
PCP you people will talk about violating
a constant fraction of the constraints
and so you make errors in a small
constant fraction of additions so you
can think of this as agreeing with the
ground state in ninety-nine percent of
locations I mean very very that's the
level of approximation that we want
which of course means that the fidelity
will be be very small good so to be the
expansion of that sense so let me go
over the what these terms are so this
means this is a good approximation if
any one of three conditions is met so
the first is if you can cluster it into
non expanding sets you get a good
approximation and that's really nothing
new that was known that's known for
classical constraint satisfaction
problems it's really not very surprising
because if you just delete all the edges
between the clusters you haven't deleted
very many edges so that's that's sort of
not very surprising but we get we get to
combine it with all the other things at
once so that part is nice second we have
good approximation of degree is high
that i think is surprising that's new to
quantum states and finally we get a good
approximation if entanglement satisfies
a sub volume law so this was asked about
earlier you know does an area law imply
a good approximation and here we have a
result that says we're looking at me a
term that's the entropy of a subsystem /
m the size of that subsystem and so
if this is the most this can be as one
if every subsystem is maximally
entangled with the rest that trip is
going to be one and at least will not
hurt the rest of the argument right this
is it just goes away and if it's much
less than one then it will mean that we
have a good approximation even if all
the other terms are as bad as possible
and so this being much less than one is
called having a sub volume law you have
a volume law if the entropy of a region
is basically equal to the size of that
region and you have a sub volume law if
the entropy is much less than that and
so in this case it says that if you have
a cell volume law so really less than
the maximum possible entanglement or
substantially lessen the maximum
possible tangle meant then you can go
further and even get a product state
approximation so it's really quite a
jump to go from less than the maximum
out of entanglement to saying in fact we
can get off for an approximation with no
entanglement that will be a pretty good
one in terms of the energy so yes so so
actually the I would like to go back to
the simple case yeah just have to grab
no clusters yes or no clusters because
that section borders has the important
message yeah and so there the messages i
am trying to formulate the message and
tell me if i am wrong yeah that um that
is so as Sanjeev asked about these
parameters so so if the ground energy is
really close to 0 then this
approximation says nothing and but
that's when the pets so that's when
actually the quantum effects kick in
like if the ground energy somewhere is
close to 1 or some kind of constant so
that's when your approximation says
something and and so then actually the
system looks pretty much like classical
because where you can approximate and
you can
proximately the product so this is how I
am interpreting I think miss you sing on
the ground to the ground the that all
the eigenvalues system are between minus
one and one so you're saying if they're
kind of that one extreme or the other
yeah so if we're lambda min I mean nice
approximation is useful but lambda min
is of the order robe you know bigger
than this error tone um yeah I mean
there's nothing uh yeah I mean it's it's
useful when you see lindemans not
naturally positive earned or negative we
have no we we have the a priori bound we
have on it is maybe that it's at most um
I mean you might the approximation is
useful when no simpler method would do
better than it so one simpler method is
just out of all the norms of all the
Hamiltonians in the system and or you
know sorry average you know take take
some trivial down to the norm like just
average all the norms of things they go
into it is it and and ask do you do is
it better than that but it's you know I
think it's not trivial as soon as the
degree is is bigger than some universal
constant like a hundred or something
yeah so it's related to what mario zinc
is it a good way to understand in the
frustration free case when you porn on
when all the terms of compare positive
semi-definite in europe want to
understand whether the ground energy is
zero or or something which is saying a
constant like as far as I said if one of
these conditions hold for example it
means that the quantum PCP cannot hold
right this is the way it should be
interpreted yeah degree is right that's
right that's right but what does it mean
for quantities me to not hold it just
means you can get a pretty crappy
approximation right PCP is you know
these are these are approximations that
screw up a small constant fraction of
the constraints so you know
frustration-free that's that's still
asking is there a single constraint that
violated Rosie row
drinks and we're very very very far from
that you this is the weakest kind of
approximation that's non-trivial yeah
you know which is which I would call
that the PCPD range I'm hoping I don't
ask questions but there will be a lot of
peace be tomorrow also i just want to
mention that yeah the role of capital v
the expansion will explain better why
that comes in denominator imagine well
that's the whole um so intuitively if
because of monogamy of entanglement each
vertex interact with D other vertices
and it can only let suppose here's a toy
model of monogamy and English each
system can be entangled is only one
other system and so if you do a product
state approximation then for one of
those bonds you've done a terrible job
and for d minus one of the bonds you've
done fine and so you get so what only a
1 over d fraction of the bonds have been
screwed up that's that's why a toy model
of an argument angleman would imply that
you get some kind of 1 over d error and
on the next slide I'll give you a an
actual argument but that's the sort of a
handle of your version of wine so let me
um male do a sketch of the proof um
which follows this technique of Prasad
who somewhere in the audience and his
collaborators ning ton which is the
information theoretic theoretic
technique that when Fernando and I
discovered it we wrote to 40 page papers
immediately following up on all the
implications and then I think we're
still not done following all the uses of
it it's very very exciting to see this
this formula and it's surprising cuz
it's not a very hard formula but somehow
it came as a big shock to us and the
formula is the chain rule for mutual
information and I don't know if anyone
defined on mutual information before so
let me just let me
just do it um so either one sis so in
both cases the mutual information is the
the sum of the entropies of two systems
minus the the joint entropy and the
conditional mutual information is if you
make all these conditional on a third
system so whenever you see entropy
replace it with a conditional entropy
and you can think of this as how much
does Alice know how informative is
Alice's state about Bob state and this
one can be how informative is Alice
estate about Bob state given already
having knowledge of Charlie state and
that way lets you interpret the chain
rule of mutual information which says so
the sort of the baby version of the
chain rule is that the mutual
information between a and b c is equal
to the mutual information between a B
and the mutual information of AC
conditioned on B so this is how much
does Alice know about the BC system
together well as much as she knows about
the D system plus the amount she knows
about the SI system conditioned on her
knowledge of the basis so that's the
chain rule of useful information and
there's no con again it's just expanding
out these entropy quantities and
canceling terms there's nothing there's
nothing to the proof and if you repeat
it you can say what is the mutual
information between a system X and a
series of systems y 1 through YK it's
the mutual information between x and y 1
plus between x and y 2 conditioned on y
1 and so on up to x and y que
conditioned on all the ones that come
before it so that's just an identity
that's just just expand doing these kind
of things expanding
these kind of terms and canceling things
and what you get from it is something
actually kind of found which is if this
x system has dimension D then the
left-hand side has is that most log D
but the right-hand side has k terms so
the smallest one of those should be
pretty small it should be at most log D
over K we don't know which term so let's
call it t the particular term but it
means that at least one of those cysts X
should be uncorrelated from at least one
of the wives of T's conditioned on all
the previous ones um and so what this
means if you have a collection of n
systems is that if i choose indices I
and J 1 through JK at random then for
some choice of tea I will have
conditional near independence so X I and
XJ will be nearly independent once I
condition on a j1 through JT and here
I'm just leaving JT + 1 to be to bj so I
choose a bunch of things at random and
conditioned on T of them and then
condition on those an average pair of
other two systems will be nearly
independent so this is just basic
classic information theory but it
already gets us most of the way home
because um what it says is that if we
discard the systems that we conditioned
on well that's at most K systems so k is
small maybe that's not too much error
and the resulting probability
distribution is nearly independent for
all pairs and the only thing we have to
do to relate it to our actual problem is
we have to say well this was an average
over all pairs we have a particular
graph ok I've erased it but you know we
have this particular graph described in
interactions when we really care about
is how independent are you across the
edges of that graph and so there we have
to pay
some you know that level of correlation
across edge of the graph might be much
higher than the average correlation and
it might be hired by a factor of n over
D because that's how many more edges
there are in the complete graph then in
our particular graph which is d regular
so that's sort of the the essence of the
argument if you condition out a bunch of
systems then you're nearly independent
across all of the edges in in your graph
now you might be a little worried that
everything I said was classical there's
nothing nothing quantum here so how much
this argument still goes through
quantumly so some part still work so the
chain rule still works on pin screws
inequality which you need if you want to
go from mutual information being small
to trace distance being small that still
works quantumly as well one thing that's
not so good is you can't condition on
quantum information so in this last one
we had to condition on the states of the
things of the j1 through JT systems
that's no longer that no longer works
quantumly you can't condition on the
state of a quantum system on ABC in this
in this quantum setting um events a B
and C are our systems are subsystems so
you have a a quantum state on I'm
several systems like like cute it's
think of them as as you know you have it
you started off with n q-tips and a B
and C might be individual ones of those
okay values of those q random vectors
are unbearable there's a quantum a log
of random variance a quantum barrel yeah
that's right uh another new difficulty
is that we want to argue that it that if
you're that conditioned on a third
system you have almost no mutual
information then you must be nearly
product conditioned on those and yet it
does not it turns out to not imply that
your state is nearly is nearly separable
um and here too I believe that no one
has defined separately
States before that let me I'll define it
anyway in in case you don't remember the
definition so the set of separable
States is the convex hull of all
products density matrices so these are
the states that have no entanglement
that have only only classical
correlation and if conditions on the
third system to a and B are completely
independent then that means that they
are separable that means that that third
system is like a classical index and
this the system of a B is that written
is just a convex combination of
completely independent things however
this is that hold approximately if your
if your system is a prolific conditional
mutual information is approximately here
that doesn't mean that you are
approximately separable so there are
things here which which are
mathematically somewhat difficult
however there's a very easy resolution
to a lot of them which is we can just
map to the classical problem so we can
just measure every system or imagine we
measure every system using something
called an informational e complete
measurement and all that means is that
the measurement from the measurement
statistics you have enough information
to reconstruct the original quantum
state and these are well known how to do
this you get some distortion so you've
the information is all there but the
distinguish ability of the quantum
states goes down by a factor that's
polynomial of dimension and in
particular what this looks like is if n
is your quantum measurement then the
trace distance of the measurement
outcomes is at most the trades distance
of what you started with for your
quantum states and at least a 1-over
polynomial and d factor times the
original trees distance and this formula
the the middle term here is a distance
of probability distributions a classical
variational distance and the these terms
here that sandwiches are a quantum paper
so ill if you relate a classical and a
quantum trace distance
you're just with this with this
measurement that's enough to essentially
complete the proof um so what do you put
together the proof what does it look
like you measure an epsilon fraction of
the cute it and condition on the
outcomes then this is that most other
pair of the cutest would have low mutual
information if you were to measure them
um and this means that their their state
is within this distance to product
that's the loss that you get from your
informational II complete measurement
being being perfect um and so the
resulting witness is is a product state
across all of the all the systems and
the total error has these two
contributions and all you do is you
choose epsilon 2 to balance those two
terms that should have been d squared
and that's fine ok so my follow-up
question is that an artificial loss of
your argument because in your baby
version of monogamy entanglement I think
we've got a lot that's right that's
right so we've lost this extra
polynomial factor or something maybe in
order for that's yeah that's a good
point I um yeah it yeah we should talk
about it afterwards I don't I don't I
cannot prove to you that i love that
Polly d factor is necessary we haven't
tried too hard to optimize it because in
you don't usually think of d is small
but it's an interesting question whether
that power your applications for PCB
seem to really also on because you hear
the trade-off between capital
I think little B is not such a big deal
little D is I mean I put that in there
to be complete but I think it's fine of
little D is just some constant like to
always but still it's interesting to
know yeah 1pc be the DS concept well
then that you are making the transformer
after the transformation it's more these
constant C
target is Constantine but if you were to
disappear with d which is log n for
example but even them this fair would
not be killer killer or maybe normally
it means that allows you to take capital
if you let this quality below
and not in this whole organism that's so
now what is your conclusion there is no
point what is this no no in terms of
quantum it's a it's a partial no go
instead of just proved it it says in it
quantities we were to hold then the
degree of the interaction graph should
not be too large should be essentially
constant I think that's the that's that
the conclusion of this and the any small
clustering of the system should satisfy
a volume law for for entanglement in
addition to thing we already knew which
is that you should be explained um okay
so I am I don't talk I'm thinking talk
about parties me so I'm gonna skip my
little motivating slide of y cuanto PCP
even though it's arguably more fun than
to dry equations but let me let me tell
you more technical stuff good I began by
talking about a hierarchy of
approximations right but you pay more
and then you get a better approximation
and that's missing from what I told you
right so what happens here can we you
can pay more by having a bigger
clustering but there's no way to pay
more and just simply get a guaranteed
improvement of your approximation so
what is your profession quality depend
on well the degree and that that's just
given to you that comes from the graph
you're never going to change that it
comes from the average expansion of your
clusters may be a bigger clustering will
will drop that average expansion but
maybe not you don't have control over
that it depends on the graph and could
well be that as you cluster more and
more the things are always expanding a
lot also the average entropy again it
may well be that as you cluster more and
more your systems always have a have a
volume law and so there's no way to sort
of spend more to take a larger witness
and get a systematically better
approximation and so that is I think an
unsatisfying piece of this work
however I will now tell you about a way
in which and we have found a way to
spend more and and get more in doing so
but with partial success and what that
is is so in the same paper that develop
this we also looked at a case in which
you could find the ground that ground
state approximation efficiently so
evidence it before is about an NP
approximation just does a good product
that exists but give you no help in
finding it and it may well be NP hard to
find it depending on your on your
problem so one way you can attempt to
find it is by using an sdp higher and
this sunday i'll talk more about
tomorrow but i just want to briefly
mention today that a possible algorithm
for doing it which is to optimize over
the following seven different program
take your variables to be all density
matrices for subsets of k or fewer
cubits or huge sorry said cube it's cute
it's whatever systems and then what
constraints to impose well one obvious
one is if two of these subsets overlap
they should be consistent on the overlap
and there's another one which is a sort
of global PSD constraint um which I'm
going to define tomorrow so let me let
me just not say what it is now but if
you're familiar with Lasserre then
you'll know that there's another global
constraint that uh that shows up so in a
different paper by prasad and his
co-authors with with bose baracan and
david stirrer they showed that this
works for classical constraint
satisfaction problems when k so k now is
a parameter as you turn it up you pay
exponentially more but your
approximation gets better and prasad is
co-author show that this works when k is
much larger than the threshold rank of
the graph the threshold rank is the
number of large I ghen values of the
adjacency matrix and we can show that
this works in the quantum case as well
Atlee
when you have a good product state
approximation so you can find a good of
course classically that's what they
showed and we show that it can find also
a good product state in the quantum case
and also of course this cake converges
to n this will eventually give you exact
answer k is equal to n this is just
exact diagonalization so at that point
you're spending exponential time so this
does interpolate between something very
cheap and something that's expensive and
gives you the exact answer however
there's something still unsatisfying
about it which is the only type of fate
it will ever return for you as a product
state it will not give you some family
of increasingly entangled states that
converges to the right answer but it
gives you a you know the only way we
could figure out how to return a state
from this is it is to get a product
state and just to put in context how
this works we have the true ground state
energy and we have two types of
approximations to it so if you want
there's one type which is called a
variational bound and this is just come
up with a model of a state and plug that
in and calculate the energy of that and
that was the first theorem I told you
where you come up with a product state
that's an example of a of a guest for
the ground state the ground state is one
of the lowest energy by definition so
any other state you plug in will give
you whatever that energy is will give
you an upper bound in the ground state
energy so the variational bounds give
you upper bounds in the ground state
energy now this stp is a relaxation you
optimize over density matrices that are
locally compatible but may not extend to
a true state for the entire system and
so this is a relaxation in that one
possibility is that this includes the
possibility of using the ground states
true reduced density matrices but also
include some spurious density matrices
that do not extend to a global solution
and so it will always give you something
that's less than or equal to the true
energy and so in practice people like to
use both of these methods because if you
find that their clothes didn't give a
rigorous proof that the ground state
energy must be in a narrow range
but there's something missing from a
theoretical point of view which i think
is a great open problem which is this
sdp rat relaxation improves with k as we
turn up k we provably get a better and
better approximation that approaches the
right thing but the variational upper
bounds are stuck the only one we have
our products takes there's no systematic
way of getting better and better ones in
1d we have matrix products case but if
there's no natural 1d structure to your
system we don't have a way of
systematically getting getting better
approximations so I think that's a kind
of a great problem to to figure out in
the future um and I think that that
doing so may require a better being able
to quantify entanglement and I have
essentially zero time left to for my
talk is that about right to let me in
any case take one minute to say that you
know here we have pure bipartisan
entanglement with ashwin ashman talked
about mixed entanglement is a total mess
and I've listed here a ton of
entanglement measures for mixed quantum
states and the only thing we can really
agree on is that separable states should
have zero entanglement and pure state
should have a containment corresponding
to their entropy I want to show you this
is the table of the properties of
different entertainment measures this is
a set of relations between different
mixed data and take measures from
matthias castanos thesis there's a
complete mess and I think that one of
the challenges is can we come up with
better entangled measures that really do
quantify in terms of you know like we
had in such a nice way for quantum
circuits before is there some kind of
nisan tainment measure that could
quantify the hardness of approximating
quantum systems another approach this is
via conditional mutual information but I
am out of time and we'll skip that and
we'll also skip this topic which is a
very nice one
and I'll also skip the question of
dynamics and I will conclude by saying
with an open question which is if we do
believe that exponential quantum
speed-up or conversely hardness is
because of entanglement then how can we
make this quantitative um and the answer
may include some subset of a better in
tainment measure so a lot of the
previous ones I think have not been very
operational or and/or have not been very
easy to compute not connected to
computational topics so we would like to
do a better job with inhuman measures we
would like to have better classical ways
to describe quantum states we had some
my work with Fernando and some partial
success of product states but we really
need to find a way to systematically
improve those matrix Prada phase for one
waves that are really great they work
well in 1d but not otherwise yes it may
include better understanding conditional
mutual information you sell a little bit
of how it came up in my proof of the of
the PCP no-go theorem but there's a lot
more we can do um and also this thing I
didn't quite mention this is approximate
quater markup states so even if i skip
some of the details I think you can
appreciate that having a systematic way
of describing the complexity of quantum
states is a desirable goal and hopefully
quantum information theory can can help
us do that hey thanks for your attention
so you can do a compression if you had a
chance to speak like that right so for
dynamic so what're dynamics it's time
evolution of a quantum system so that
means Hamiltonian and then some noise
terms and we know in terms of noise /
gate if you have very little noise then
fault your fault on quantum computing
that's just because we complete you have
Universal chronic computing if there's a
lot of noise classical simulation is
possible but there's this big
intermediate regime that we don't really
know what to say about and if there some
here's a question I think we'd like to
answer can we simulate lightly entangle
dynamics namely if you knew the
entanglement was always less than k then
can you do some simulation that runs in
overhead exponential intake and not only
is the question open but I don't even
know how to find the question because
what does it even mean for entanglement
to be less than K i think defining that
is like a big part of what's missing
from it exactly so we know only we know
the exact we know the extreme and we
don't know how to perturb it yeah we
know that the attainment is always zero
you can simulate that's your state's
over this mixed it um mixed so actually
this is an old paper of me and Michael
Nielsen I was like my third paper like
that on a day and if it's pretty it's
pretty easy you what happens is suppose
you have some noisy dynamic so that you
never create an entanglement then you
start off with a pure state by
assumption and then you take one step
and you get a separable states and this
separable state is a mixture of product
tapes so you just sample one of those
and it's not very complicated so I will
say it just involves two qubits so
that's a harder sample and that's it now
you have another product fate and you
keep going and you've sampled you've
simulated the evolution so if you're
always if you if you have operations
that you not create the entanglement
then you're fine this is
from the whole NMR thing that's that's
another beast um but this is for non
entangling operations um so so the
operations yeah that's what we know is
that the operations are not entangling
and and that's sort of so winter I put
the dude a picture because you know a
lot of people are like me are very
skeptical of d-wave achieving anything
useful but if we want to prove the
d-wave has not achieved anything useful
the only way to prove that is I think
with a classical simulation of their of
something that's a good approximation of
their model and we know their model has
a lot of noise but you know you have to
really say that the parameters of their
noise are ones that let that can be
classically simulated I think only then
can you really conclusively say they
haven't done something useful
flow is a rounding procedure for your SD
view hierarchy we're just taking the
market you you have all marshals of
unque systems so choose a random k minus
one system set of systems measure them
in some information we complete way and
then look at the case one and then as
you move that case went around you get
an opinion of each one of the individual
systems so you'll just round into a
product that's enough and now you can
perhaps see the difficulty of rounding
anything more complicated products eat
okay one last question so you used to
divide your result simulating non
entangling the dynamics of suppose so do
you expect that if expiration of that
should be truly because I mean the
problem is if you if you're allowed to
generate a little bit of entanglement in
one step you can just repeat that step a
bunch of times so it's hard to perturb
it I don't know how to preserve it I
think what you need is some kind of
promise that you never develop too much
entanglement in some sense but it
reminds me this DQ model where we know
that isn't an results
low progress and car it depends on what
measure you use I guess right so I think
you know we haven't found an
entertainment measure that would lend
itself to to efficient simulation I mean
maybe there is maybe this earth maybe
this this agenda maybe this research
gender can be shown to not work but
that's um yeah that's what we don't know
yet
alright so let's keep some energy for
the livestock and banker